[Aplausos]
gracias a ustedes puedo hacer una
promesa y es que seguiré defendiendo a
francia en nuestras ideas
[Aplausos]
y estoy seguro de que pronto ganaremos
también los agradezco a ustedes en
nombre de francia puesto que cada uno de
sus votos es para mí el grito de un
pueblo que no quiere morir
[Aplausos]
y el hecho de que hayan sido dos
millones para apoyar a un hombre que
salió de la nada que no era un político
y esto nos muestra que mi mensaje fue
recibido fue escuchado es un elemento
fundamental que no deberá ser olvidado
en los próximos días y en los próximos
años
sus votos
nunca se podrán olvidar cualquiera que
sea el resultado de la segunda vuelta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todo el mundo comprenderá que nuestras
ideas valen mucho más que nuestro
puntaje
no supe convencer un número suficiente
de nuestros compatriotas la historia
dirá porque no lo logramos mientras que
hay una mayoría de franceses que
comparten nuestras inquietudes y
nuestras esperanzas quizás debido a la
ausencia de una campaña y de un debate
quizás debido al trato que nos fue dado
por la situación internacional también y
quizás también simplemente por culpa mía
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
[Música]
por supuesto cometí errores
y quiero decirles que lo asumo todos
asumo la total responsabilidad por mis
errores muchos de mis éxitos se los
llevo a mi equipo
y no les debo a ellos ninguno de mis
fracasos
[Aplausos]
pero al terminar esta campaña tengo el
orgullo de no haberme convertido en un
político
nunca mentí para ganar un solo punto en
los sombreros
nunca cambié mi pensamiento y nunca
abandoné
en los próximos días
ustedes van a escuchar muchas
explicaciones sobre que en dónde fue que
fallamos pero yo en cambio les diré todo
aquello en lo que tuvimos éxito a estos
millones de franceses quiero decirles
que gracias a ustedes nunca nada será
como antes
donde esté
les pido que conserven su dignidad que
sigan siendo fuertes y que sigan
teniendo fe fueron admirables durante
esta campaña su voto es un voto primero
es un voto de futuro es un voto de
esperanza puesto que las verdades que le
dijimos a francia durante esta campaña
se impondrán a todos en los próximos
años
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
quiero agradecer desde el fondo de mi
corazón a todos los que me ayudaron a
todo nuestro equipo a todos nuestros
militantes un inmenso agradecimiento
muchas gracias
y su energía su fervor su grandeza de
espíritu su generosidad su organización
impresionaron a toda francia todavía
recuerdo del mes de mayo pasado en esa
época éramos apenas unas decenas eso no
era sino una idea veíamos el bloqueo de
la vida política francesa
veíamos el estado deplorable en que
estaba en francia
no sabríamos cuál sería la acogida que
tendríamos por parte de los franceses
pero sabíamos que nuestro deber era
levantarnos y yo me levanté
[Aplausos]
un año más tarde sí no aquí estamos
finalmente frente al duelo que estaba
anunciado desde el 2017 obras y
electoralmente nada cambia
políticamente si todo cambió todo cambió
porque ya llegamos y rompimos en la vida
política y miren que superamos a los
viejos partidos moribundos en tres meses
hicimos lo que ningún político logró en
15 años hemos construido
el partido más grande de francia
[Aplausos]
tengo a mi lado una juventud que se
levantó y esta juventud es la
prohibición no tiene permitido
desesperarse porque no va a desaparecer
las
banderas que flotaron en el trocadero
nunca volverán a caerse nunca se caerán
[Aplausos]
entonces sí claro estamos decepcionados
pero ganamos en esta campaña algo que no
tiene precio y es la potencia y la
experiencia les digo querida reconquista
somos potentes somos poderosos son los
fuertes tenemos militantes en toda
francia tenemos inteligencias grandes y
ccoo de
competencias sin igual ya nos estamos
proyectando hacia el futuro
pero no me quedaré aquí porque
reconquista nunca ha abandonado nada
mientras que no logremos reconquistar a
francia
[Aplausos]
nuestra línea tiene una singularidad y
no está representada en ninguna otra
parte
somos los únicos que defendemos nuestra
civilización y nuestra identidad
en la cultura en la escuela en las
calles en nuestras costumbres en nuestra
visión de la ecología y de la política y
de la sociedad somos los únicos que
queremos reconciliar al pueblo y a las
élites a los asalariados y a los
empleadores
a los chalecos amarillos y a la
manifestación para todos la política en
general estoy determinado a continuar
con este combate con todos los que me
acompañan todos los que quieran unirse a
mí en las próximas semanas y les diré
qué forma tendrá nuestra acción muy
pronto
pienso ante todo en francia porque ese
era todo el sentido de mi candidatura
no puedo quedarme de brazos cruzados
ante los males que hace que enfrenta
nuestro país estoy en desacuerdo con
marín diop en favor de estas diferencias
durante esta campaña no voy a decir la
lista
pero frente a marin de pena hay un
hombre que ha hecho entrar a dos
millones de inmigrantes al nombre que no
ha hablado de una ni una sola palabra de
identidad 9 seguridad de la inmigración
en su campaña y que pronto sería peor si
es reelegido no me voy a equivocar de
haber salud por esta razón les llamo a
mis electores a votar por marín dopen
[Aplausos]
hay algo mucho más grande que nosotros
todos si es francia sé que algunos de
mis electores no van a querer votar por
ella no los juzgo puesto que acepte las
diferencias en el seno de las la unión
de las derechas algunos hubieran querido
que yo negociar a estas pocas palabras
pero yo no soy un comerciante
[Aplausos]
no veo la política como una negociación
de intereses sino como la irrupción de
la voluntad humana en la historia me
presenté
por francia porque creo que nuestro país
está en peligro me presenté porque el
duelo que se anunciaba desde hacía cinco
años me parecía que llevaba al fracaso
de nuestras ideas hoy ruego al cielo
haberme equivocado viva la república y
sobre todos y sobre todo viva francia